hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash finale video oh my god
they did all the comic book things just
careful for spoilers we got to talk
about all these drags and what it means
for season three it's a little bit
easier to chart the path of the flash
because they stick a little bit closer
to notable comic book storylines and
even though it does seem like they're
doing flashpoint in season three because
of that big twist at the end that
doesn't mean it'll be exactly like
flashpoint but they said there'd be a
big four-way crossover flashpoint was
this universe altering thing in the
comics so we can talk about that in a
second let's do top 10 WTF and I'll do
comic book Easter eggs as we go along
the notable big comic book storylines
that they did were crisis on Infinite
Earths the final run of zoom on the
flash that was during the Wally West era
before flash rebirth in then flashpoint
of course number 10 WTF in the aftermath
from the last episode they open with
that scream it was such a great way to
open the episode they put you inside
Barry's head
they take the sound away so you only
hear the music it's almost like his ears
are ringing
and he can't hear anything because he's
in this crazy state of shock like his
brain can't handle what just happened
drives him over the edge and he can't
bring himself to kill zoom till another
zooms surprise surprise comes along and
kills that other zoom so number 9 WTF we
learned this zoom has been trying to
break the rules of the Speed Force
turns out the Speed Force doesn't like
to have its rules broken he's speaking
like a crazy person would speak you have
to remember the TV show has given a
consciousness to the Speed Force in a
way that the comics has not in the
comics it's an energy source there's no
intelligence behind it on the TV show
it's a little bit more like the wormhole
aliens of ds9 which does kind of make
you wonder if there's evil Speed Force
aliens out there somewhere but the
funeral number 8 WTF a lot of funerals
happening in the DC Universe especially
with arrow and laurels death so this is
really a somber occasion they have all
these nice speeches Joe gives a speech
that sounds a lot like what's happening
on arrow right now where people are
trying to have hope in a moment of
darkness even though they kind of took
it away at the end because of what Barry
did he almost seems like he's coming to
terms with it but then he just can't
handle it runs back in time and just
completely messes everything up so it's
almost like Joe's speech was wasted on
him he's like the only member of team
flash that isn't really processing all
this we get a nice Cisco transformers
burn
and just to lighten the mood a little
bit then number seven WTF zoom gives
Barry the ultimatum a race to see who's
the fastest so in the comics if you read
the Wally West era hunter zolomon zooms
whole mission was to push Wally to make
him better use tragedy as an engine to
fuel
Wally's evolution but we know on the TV
show that a big thing with flash
villains is trying to trick Barry into
giving them what they want so they they
tell them oh hey let's have this race
when really their plan is to power this
giant engine that's going to destroy the
multiverse
but thankfully number six lwt's you have
team flash is smarter than Barry
realizes that he just can't handle this
and lock him up you go into timeout
mister I think there was even some zoom
dialogue where he's like come to the
dark side use your anger let it flow
through you all I could think of was
Star Wars it was so funny this is where
we get to number five WTF crisis on
Infinite Earths Easter eggs so the
magnetar looks suspiciously like the
anti monitors gun during crisis on
Infinite Earths what it was was a weapon
of last resort that he was going to use
to destroy the last of the multiverse
the main earth that the Justice League
was from was also a fulcrum so he
destroyed that it started to topple the
rest of the multiverse so to save
everyone Barry has to run around it at
SuperSpeed to dismantle to basically
destroy it but in doing so sacrifices
himself his body can't handle the energy
because he's running so fast so that's
where the time remnant logic comes in I
wonder if they wanted to end on this
moment first like they knew they wanted
to end on this big crisis moment and
then as a way to explain how Barry could
survive it they came up with this time
remanent twist and then tried to kind of
weave that in like what came first did
the time remnant idea come first or did
the crisis idea come first I feel like
the crisis thing came first and then
they tried to find some logic to make it
work it's not really a complaint I do
feel like they did a good job this
season of having internal consistency
they always change minor things from the
comics so it's not a big surprise that
they tried to use some of this and make
it work together
number four we get the rest of the zoom
back story we find out that he's been to
a lot of other Earth's he just happened
to run into the real Jay Garrick on one
of them so he stole him in knowing that
he was Barry's father decided to keep
him around for some fun later if he
wanted to he also did the real
nice thing I was really happy the
writers did this where they spell the
timeline out so he got speed force
powers then said that wasn't enough
develop the velocity-6 drug use that to
go to other dimensions and that's when
he started to have problems his body
started to generate so that's where we
get into the velocity-9 storyline so
everything he was talking about happened
before we met him for the first time in
season two number three the final battle
was zoom time remanent Barry is able to
blow up the device in a way that's very
much like his death during crisis on
Infinite Earths and gives the time race
a reason to come for zoom as they they
take him away surprise surprise he looks
a lot like the black flash of the comics
with the red emblem here in the Haunted
face of the skeleton look so the actor
explained that he can totally come back
in the future but I don't know
necessarily that he was talking about
flashpoint reasons that this version of
zoom might not be gone for good but
there's a number of different ways they
could go if they want to bring him back
for a cameo that is one of the most
beautiful things about comic book logic
is that everything has been done any
twist you could possibly imagine there
is an explanation for it somewhere in
the comics no matter how ridiculous it
is but some of you may have seen this
and recognized that this is from ghost
this is how the villain dies during
ghost the really old Patrick Swayze Demi
Moore movie and there was a Family Guy
joke where Joe gets carried away after
the episode were they introduced the
idea of time race I did wonder if that
would be how they carried zoom off
because he just kept going on and on
about breaking the laws of the Speed
Force so it's that you know felt like in
some way the Speed Force would act
against him number two of course the
real Jay Garrick reveal is John Wesley
Shipp like we had all hoped they made
something right the flash originally got
canceled after season during the 90s
which when you hear the real reason for
white Council it wasn't because of low
ratings it got cancelled because the
executives shuffled from behind the
scenes so it makes me even more pissed
so they're just making things right the
costume that he's wearing looks a little
bit like his classic 90s costume just a
little bit bulkier he's a pretty big guy
anyway they give him the Jay Garrick hat
oh maybe I'll take something in his and
use it for hope but he's going back to
earth 3 but I think they're going to do
let's forget about flashpoint for a
second and changing the timeline is
they're just saying that he'll come back
and visit on occasion just in the way
that
Marie Allen appeared a few times this
season he was in the last couple of
episodes but he's not a regular so he's
not going to be in every single episode
it's just that now there's a real Jay
Garrick out there and he's John Wesley
Shipp so that is just so perfect it made
me so happy to see that number one of
course is throwing the world into
flashpoint if you've never read the
comic book storyline or you haven't seen
the animated movie they did make an
animated movie of it but it's not quite
as broad as the comic berry goes back in
time and prevents his mother from dying
but in doing so completely messes the
timeline up he never becomes the flash
and people that used to be friends like
the Justice League essentially fractures
and winds up fighting each other
destroying the earth in the process he
becomes this hellish nightmare in the
reverse-flash is just laughing the whole
time you Bart Don is like you did this I
didn't do this
the reason the earth has turned into
hell is because of something that you
did so I think we can all agree that
season three is going to look a lot like
flashpoint Barry is going to have to fix
his mistake that is going to be the big
hurdle to jump over so if he's gonna do
that that means he's going to have to go
back in time again another time and let
his mother be murdered remember at the
end of season 1 where Barry goes back in
time the reverse flash is like look
here's an opportunity to save your
mother but when he goes to save her the
other version of the flash reaches out
and just shakes his head don't do it
don't save her that means now that there
are three versions of Barry in that
moment there's the one there from the
first timeline that takes young Barry
away saves him while his mother's being
murdered the second version of Barry
from the end of season 1 that went back
and then the third version that we just
saw so there are three Barry Allen's in
this moment right here
and what about eobard thawne did he kill
him here are we going to see this moment
from the end of season one remember we
flash we saw Barry in prison this is
trial of the flash he goes to trial in
the comics because he killed eobard
thawne to prevent him from killing iris
in the past so that's kind of what he
did with his mother this kind of feels
like it might be trial of the flash so
they might address that at the beginning
of season 3 when the cops show up
there's a dead body here what's going on
so they just they have to follow up on
that moment but let me know in the
comment
but your favorite moment from the
episode there was a lot of heart they
had a lot of great moments there was the
kiss with Iris I love you I love you too
that's probably going to get trampled on
next season because of what Barry did
but I will say I'll be just a little
upset if they don't address different
timelines on the other shows I give
arrow season 5 legends of tomorrow or
Supergirl season 2 don't address this at
all it'd be a really easy backdoor for a
flashpoint team-up because that was a
Justice League story and they kind of
have just a society now because super
girls on the CW so there's just a number
of different directions they could go
I'm not expecting full-blown flashpoint
each show will have its own narrative
its own big bed its own finale but if
the flash is going to go back and change
something this big from this big of a
comic book story then there's no way
that they could completely ignore it on
the other TV shows but the cool thing is
is that the writers just went back to
work this week so they're already
writing season three arcs so we might
hear some stuff about what's going on
real soon but it's so much awesome stuff
I feel like if you guys haven't already
you should go read flashpoint is
actually a pretty good story even though
DC rebirth is dropping tomorrow it's so
funny how they're doing such a big
universe altering story on the flash TV
show but they're also rebooting a whole
bunch of DC comic book continuity so
what happened is is DC rebirth is
essentially going to wipe the new 52 off
the map it's completely retconning that
and it's weaving in 80 years of
comic-book history so if you have
absolutely no idea what the new 52 is
you don't have to read any of it now but
effectively it was DC Comics behind the
scenes hitting a hard reset button on
all of its characters instead that
everything that's happened before isn't
canon anymore we're starting with brand
new Canon and everybody got pissed sales
worked terrible so now Geoff Johns
you know flew in to the rescue and his
Superman cape with his Green Lantern
ring and said I'm going to fix this so
we have DC rebirth so if you ever wanted
to start reading comics now is the time
to start doing it DC rebirth number one
drops tomorrow but what's going to
happen next is after I post my arrow
finale video I'll post my flash season 3
predictions just based on all this I'll
talk more about flashpoint stuff and how
the universe might be changed a little
bit and there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so much awesome comic-book
stuff happening this week why you guys
wait for my next video you can click
here for my code or Q&A from last night
and you can click here for my flash
season 3 Supergirl season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight